[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this a practical joke
oh [ __ ] don't have money for books we
got money for this little thang khuu
all you gotta do is put in your order
and it does the rest coffee you're gonna
[ __ ] that coffee machine up I know are
rough school but this is the worst I've
ever seen the pranks something weird
about this field you're standing on a
giant dick man
you kids are out of control think this
is funny messing with the TV with your
goddamn computer telephone
it's a weird though seeing these kids
grow up in one damn it's just like BAM
they're 18 and you can [ __ ] him no these
students [ __ ] on this school all day oh
and don't nobody do nothing imma show
you what's fun
I can't wait to [ __ ] you up I'm sorry
what we're gonna hand to our differences
like real mean what difference is you
got a job and not don't that's the
[ __ ] difference
would you challenge mr. Campbell to a
fistfight I'll see you at 3 o'clock
here's a nice guy and then people are
like hey I'm gonna stomp on that guy he
most doublings go knock all the sex out
of you
snitches get stitches he's holding an
axe just arrest the guy care to respond
[ __ ] the police
[Music]
kids they got it all hopped up on
homemade math it's not the best batch
well I'm sorry
how do you know that how do I know what
need the guidance counselor don't do
math period what am i my period don't do
it that's what I needed the most I'm
done with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] me Campbell's gonna [ __ ] right back
he's gonna get in a fistfight
[Music]
[ __ ] little [ __ ] sons of
[ __ ] fishes getting vomit
I look like a [ __ ] million
he did it now you got to pay the price
snitches get stitches which is what
you're talking about
mr. Strickland reputation of a